Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
En un día largo vagando por el bosque
para encontrar granos y hierbas,
el granjero Shennong, agotado y divino,
se envenenó 72 veces por accidente.
Pero antes de que el veneno
terminará con su vida,
una hoja cayó en su boca.
La masticó y revivió,
y es así cómo descubrimos el té.
O, por lo menos, eso dice la leyenda.
El té actualmente no cura venenos,
pero la historia de Shennong,
el mítico inventor chino
de la agricultura,
destaca la importancia
del té en la China antigua.
La evidencia arqueológica
sugiere que el té fue cultivado allá
hace 6000 años,
o 1500 años antes de que los faraones
construyeran las grandes
pirámides de Guiza.
Esa planta china original del té
es de la misma clase que se cultiva
hoy en todo el mundo,
aunque se consumió
al principio de manera diferente.
Se comió como verdura o cocinada
con gachas de avena.
El té solo cambia de ser comido
a ser bebido hace 1500 años
cuando la gente vio que
la combinación del calor y la humedad
podía generar un sabor complejo
y variado con esas hojas.
Tras cientos de años con variaciones
del método de preparación,
el estándar se convirtió
en calentar el té,
empaquetarlo en bloques portables,
molerlo en polvo,
mezclarlo con agua caliente
y crear una bebida llamada
muo cha, o matcha.
El matcha se volvió tan popular que surgió
la distintiva cultura del té en China.
El té fue el tema de libros y poesía,
la bebida favorita de emperadores
y en un medio para artistas.
Dibujaban imágenes
extravagantes en la espuma del té,
muy parecido al arte del expresso
que se vea hoy en las tiendas del café.
En el siglo IX, durante la dinastía Tang,
un monje japonés llevó
la primera planta de té a Japón.
Los japoneses desarrollaron
sus propios rituales únicos con el té,
creando la ceremonia japonesa del té.
Y en el siglo XIV
durante la dinastía Ming,
el emperador chino cambió la norma
del té en bloques
al té de hoja suelta.
Entonces China todavía tenía un monopolio
de los árboles del té del mundo,
haciendo del té una de las tres
exportaciones esenciales de China,
junto con la porcelana y la seda.
Este dio un gran poder e
influencia económica a China
cuando beber té
se difundió en todo el mundo.
Esa difusión comenzó sobre
el principio de 1600,
cuando comerciantes holandeses llevaron
té a Europa en grandes cantidades.
Muchos atribuyen a la Reina
Catherine de Braganza, noble portuguesa,
el hacer popular el té
entre la aristocracia inglesa
al casarse con el Rey Carlos II en 1661.
Entonces Gran Bretaña estaba en proceso
de expansión de su influencia colonial
convirtiéndose en el nuevo
poder dominante del mundo.
Y al crecer Gran Bretaña, el interés
por el té se difundió en todo el mundo.
Por 1700 el té en Europa se vendía
a un precio 10 veces más alto que el café
y la planta todavía
se cultivaba solo en China.
El comercio del té era tan lucrativo
que Clipper, la nave
más rápida del mundo,
se creó debido a la competencia intensa
entre compañías comerciantes del oeste.
Todos competían
por llevar el té a Europa rápido
para maximizar sus ganancias.
Primero Gran Bretaña pagó
por el té chino con plata.
Al resultar demasiado caro,
propusieron intercambiar el té
con otra substancia, el opio.
Eso provocó un problema
de salud pública en China,
porque la gente se volvió
adicta a la droga.
En 1839 un funcionario chino
ordenó a sus hombres
destruir cargamentos inmensos
de opio de Gran Bretaña
como declaración contra la influencia
de Gran Bretaña sobre China.
Este acto provocó la Primera
Guerra del Opio entre las dos naciones.
Luchando por toda la costa hasta 1842,
cuando la dinastía Qing derrotada cedió
el puerto de Hong Kong a Gran Bretaña
y reasumió el comercio
en condiciones desfavorables.
La guerra debilitó la posición global
de la China durante más de un siglo.
La compañía británica de las Indias
Orientales quiso cultivar té sola
y así controlar más el mercado.
Entonces encargaron
al botánico Robert Fortune
robar té en China
en una operación encubierta.
Se disfrazó y emprendió
un viaje peligroso
por las regiones de las montañas
del té en China,
contrabandeando los árboles
del té y trabajadores especializados
en Darjeeling, India.
Desde allá, la planta se difundió aún más,
contribuyendo a aumentar
la rápida expansión como bien diario.
Hoy el té es la bebida más consumida
en el mundo después del agua,
y desde el té dulce turco de Rize
al té salado del Tíbet,
existen casi tantas maneras
de preparar la bebida
como culturas en el mundo.